so he just said we haven't gotten there
yet to reply to every tweet i SAT and
looked the best buy right then and there
I can do it myself so I don't know why
fest I can't hire an intern for zero
dollars and zero cents and do it see
everybody [ __ ] talks about it but
nobody doesn't and what I'm obsessed
with is this then a little Jersey boy
like me could go out and buy a camera
for 300 bucks sit down and put out
content about the thing that I love the
most right and compete with people like
the wine spectator and decanter magazine
and Robert Parker who've got 25 years of
equity who've got millions of dollars
behind them and that is a huge change
when I started really realizing it I
called the Zagat family if you guys know
what's if God is is it got ratings for
restaurants so you know in the US
there's a big rating system for
restaurants you might have seen if
you've ever been 25 out of 25 there it
was huge of the multi-million dollar
business the second day that Yelp was in
the market I called them and said you
need to pay attention to this right now
because if you don't counter this you're
going to be out of business at night in
nine months to years careers really
didn't matter they completely laughed it
off then I saw them here later and they
were kind of a little bit more intrigued
and now they call me every day saying
health and I'm like [ __ ] it's over
that ship has sailed and so what I'm
excited about is this what I wrote that
book about that comes out a couple weeks
is this that we live in a day at the age
that I am convinced that eighty-five
percent of you that I'm looking at right
now do not love what you're doing one
hundred fifty percent you just don't and
in my opinion three years ago that was
fine but today it's not because the cost
of entry to be in the game around your
passion is zero it costs zero dollars to
have a tumblr account
let the host your domain for you it
costs basically two hundred bucks a
hundred bucks to buy a flip camera an
iphone that has video on it if you want
to create video or you can write or
audio not everybody is extroverted as we
it doesn't have to be a knowledge of not
everybody is charismatic and handsome
and smart as I am by then but you have
to know who you are and companies need
to know after know who they are you
can't be when you're not and you need to
embrace what you are holy that's what we
deal with what the companies that we
talk to know who you are you know the
NHL wants to be the NFL you're not the
[ __ ] nsl you know get over that
understand what you are and execute
against what you are and I think the
fact of the matter is that you can build
your brand out by getting your hands
dirty you know this crazy little thing
that's super super underrated it's
called working really hard the fact that
you can work really hard and actually
filled a business today is so different
than it used to be because going to
searched on Twitter and finding people
talking about the things that you do is
easy and all you have to do is add reply
them and talk to them and there's a
trillion niche sites around your subject
there's thousands tens of thousands of
wine blogs and I don't care if their
number four on Alexa or compete or
number eight million it's a person and
actually caring about the people that
talk about your rant whether they have
400,000 followers on Twitter or seven
it's a [ __ ] human being you should
give a [ __ ] and plus the person that has
70 by the way might have 400,000 one day
and so I think that we're living in this
insane shift we're clearly eyeballs are
shifting they're going in a different
direction people are consuming media and
all sorts of different platforms and the
fact that we all as individuals have
ability to tap into that with work and
skills obviously listen you can be as
packed listen I'm passionate as crap
about football I cannot be an NFL
quarterback you know I get it so you
have to know that part cold but if you
want to produce content what I'm
obsessed about is my friend who knows
more about gardening than is healthy but
he spends 12 hours a day in forums and
reading blogs about gardening and if he
was to cut out three hours of that and
produce that content he can quit his
[ __ ] corporate job that he hates
with his whole life and moved to this
snap not overnight I get it but I
promise you I'm sitting in these budget
meetings there's going to be a trillion
dollars in a grab and a buys in five
years and they want to spend it in
different places because debating if
television works I get that it works but
please don't talk to me about the
metrics of television when we stick a
box in every 4,000 homes and count it as
real stupid
what I know is this all of us every
person in this room no matter what
business you're in you're all in the
same business as I we are in the
eyeballs business and wherever I don't
know about you guys but every time
somebody comes up to me and says well
how's Twitter gonna make money or
facebook i vomit directly in my mouth
[ __ ] when you have billions of
eyeballs you can monetize and that's
interesting to me it's interesting to me
that how many people don't get it it's
interesting to me of how many people
don't do what they love it's interesting
to me how much everything's changed and
we've taken it for granted we're under
rating what's happened here the internet
that we all know and I know nerds don't
get mad at me i'm i'm going to Clause 14
years I get it's been around for 40 or
50 1 ml but the internet that we know
the one that if you lived in America
when AOL started sending you see these
in the mail when windows 95 came out
that thing that thing is 14 [ __ ]
years old 14 nothing happens in 14 years
the internet hasn't had sex yet and it
is completely disturbing the way we
brand and built a business how we get to
users Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
get all the credit they're [ __ ] tools
on top of the bigger later right I mean
they're a marker Facebook's a damn stamp
Stabler you know Twitter's a bunch of
markers you know you know it companies
came up to me last year like I've got a
Twitter account what do you want to
[ __ ] cookie build a business off of
that what I know is this to have the
cost of entry be 0 like it is today and
to make excuses of why you're not
building or why you're not hearing what
I'm excited about is this everybody
talks about how transparent and
authentic it is it really is right
because my DNA gets me excited when I
see a lot of people up here and I come
up here and start cursing for god knows
why and there's a lot of people that
don't necessarily like the over-the-top
extroverted bravado that I bring to the
table other people like that it's
authentic and real the fact that matter
is this though because we have the
ability to engage with people on a
one-to-one level now whether virtual in
our Underpants at home or what is very
powerful because for my brand it's been
very successful for the brands that have
gotten her hands dirty and gotten over
themselves and got into the trenches
it's been successful and most of all the
consumer has changed you know I don't
see a pretty girl now and grab a club
and hit her in a head and dragged her by
the hair we've evolved as human beings
so have the consumers they don't want to
be sold to the way everybody's used to
they want a piece of it they want you to
give a crap they want to engage whether
you're a brand or a celebrity and if you
don't adjust to that and if you throw
lines in the sand of what you want
instead of what they want you have
absolutely no shot of winning in this
game and so much more is coming how many
in this room are from
with boxxy be 0 x e raise your hand not
a lot please write it down and check out
boxy dot TV I think they might've bought
calm now I don't know if foxy is going
to be friendster and be too early and
not win but I can tell you right now the
concept of boxy is going to win and when
cable television at least in the u.s.
it's something I understand a little
better when TV falls people going to
[ __ ] their pants cuz then things are
gonna change because then brands are
gonna be scattered they're gonna try to
figure out because what brands like to
do is they like to be really lazy
they'll either just say here's 12
million dollars we know we get the
eyeballs or they think because there's a
box that every 4,000 homes for whatever
and so to me what happens with that
opportunity when everything shifts when
the eyeballs go in different places I
used to buy billboards and bus stop that
and tax the ads for wine library until I
was walking down the street and
everybody in New York City was coming at
me like this and I was like [ __ ] they're
not looking at my add any more things
change people aren't thinking about them
and to me there's a lot of excitement
opportunities in it and I know people
are scared and [ __ ] but the people in
this room unless you work for a gigantic
company if anything that happened that
would make me excited it would be that
you gave substantial consideration I
know you guys know just by you guys
being here you know so much more than
ninety nine percent of the people out
there but when I think all of us
including myself have not totally
completely swallowed completely put into
our DNA is how big this ship is how
substantial ish changes and how real it
is for you to build a business around
the things you love the most and I
promise you when you do something around
the thing you love the most you'll work
the 16 hours a day to make it successful
because you love that [ __ ] and that work
with that passion
that's who wins it's obvious we see it
every day that's the game because when
you're 90 years old and laying them that
going to the other place you're gonna
care about you wish you spent more time
with your family and you're like you
know what I hated that [ __ ] job that
was [ __ ] up and I don't want that to
happen because now you can absolutely go
and grab it and listen I don't want
anybody that [ __ ] you know quit their
jobs you've got to pay bills you got
kids and right I get that I'm talking
about when you go home stop watching
[ __ ] lost stop playing madden
football stop hitting the Wii tennis
racket for nine hours don't come to me
and complain that your business blows
when you've got the highest score on the
week seriously thank you